so so you've been you've been
a part of the mossad from 64 to 96 yeah
that's 32 some years but from 89 to 96
you were the head of mossad
and obviously been retired now for 25
years has the enemy of
israel changed from 64 till today and
what has that evolution look like
or have all the enemies pretty much been
the same two three four
five candidates well the uh the world is
uh
is uh changing all the time
and the world does not does not stand
still for a moment
and uh the same goes for the middle east
and uh for the
structure of of the conflict between
israel and
its uh neighbors um
first of all we uh we can pinpoint to
uh the first uh agreement between israel
and
and and egypt and it
it was initiated
by the war of 73
on what we call yom kippur war the the
the grains
of peace with egypt started with the
with the wall of 1973.
the peace with jordan was signed in 95
after uh five six seven decades of
enmity and
and then the adversarial relationships
in egypt listen we can we can put the
line in
on on 47 for 1947 and king 48
as the baseline of uh the
uh adversarial relationship between
israel
and its its neighbors so the main the
main
the main and number one adversary were
the palestinians
who were who shared the same territory
with us
and the main cause for the conflict was
who
who owns this territory
and then our countries joined the
palestinians in the war of independence
egypt was the first one syria
jordan joined the uh
the uh palestinians and then we
found ourselves in what we named the
wall of independence
which by by the way metaphorically
i can tell you that the war of
independence
has not yet
finished even today we to a certain
to a certain extent we are still in in
in the
in our wall of independence as long as
as long as territory the territorial
question
uh is not solved and as long as there
are countries that
don't uh don't um
acknowledge the uh israel
is is as a sovereign state in
in the in the middle east um the the
wall for all particular purposes
is not yet it's not finished
and then we the era of of the cold war
um and and the walls that we had
we can we can say that uh
every decade since the uh
uh beginning of the state uh um
every decade we had at least one big war
and in between we we had
all kinds of uh of uh
small uh small military operations and
skirmishes
and and then from a certain point of
time
we had to cope with the uh phenomenon of
uh terrorism which uh for
uh three four decades
was um sort of a local domestic
event um which was a
a civil
kind of uh of uh of uh
phenomenon who who
fought for independence
and and and and
then after the uh during the uh
the uh uh spring
revolutions terrorism
uh adopted adopted the uh
the religious side of
it and and and instead of being a civil
kind of uh
of uh uh um entity
it has become a religious uh
entity in in in religion
um turn the uh phenomenon of
the terrorist phenomenon from a local
event to become global again
um the last
uh development of course is uh
what happened during the uh the last
few weeks or so that
the emirates uh countries
and the morocco
um have upgraded their
relationship with with israel and they
uh
it's a it's a very positive
uh development which uh
which may affect uh the the future of
the region
uh maybe even
towards a uh
ending the the ancient
conflict between us and the and the
palestinians so
uh the uh the situation is volatile
the situation is ending if they're
changing
all the time and of course uh
[Music]
um it's not a a
a a two-party kind of a game
all the arab all the arab world is to
certain extent
is involved in it and then we have um
regional uh powers like iran
and turkey and then we have the
global powers russians chinese and
america
who are also involved in any in this uh
playground so uh i don't know if i
if i answered you your question but
i believe that at least sparkly is
succeeding so if you like the sort of
short clip from an interview i did click
over here to watch the entire interview
and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye